one person said can't the ropes that
exist through space be considered the
ether
and another person that says the vortex
spares
which are functionally identical the
dipoles are what make up bill gates
ropes the vortex pairs self-organize
into dna-like ropes
that connect all particles together my
ether model gives a logical reason for
their existence absolutely not
not not not uh they want to turn my
bunch of particle a bunch of uh ropes
into an ether like a background
no because the ropes crisscross and
that's the
background radiation uh cosmic uh
uh what is it uh microwave background
radiation
that's uh possibly uh
vibration of neutrons and atoms out
there but it's also
uh the ropes crisscrossing throughout
the universe but each rope each atom
what contours it what's what's the stuff
that
to say stuff that contours that gives
shape to it
why doesn't the robe become or or the
atoms
become a single chunk of a block of
matter because what
chops it up you could say what separates
one from another is space what is space
space
is nothing that's what space is space is
nothing
and it's not like uh spaces is
containing in some way because space has
no way of
interfacing with matter okay
but you have to think of it as this you
have to think of it as
again the the theory or the hypothesis
the
foundation of this is that there's a
single thread floating out there that's
all there is
and if you look at that thread you say
well there's thread and what what gives
it contour what gives it contour is
space
nothing backing void
nothingness that's what's what gives it
tape because otherwise
if there were no space we would have a
single block of
matter infinite that's what we would
have there would be no motion no
anything
so the way you have to imagine this is
just a single
thread just floating is it floating in
space
is it moving through space absolutely
not nothing moves through space or
in space because space is not a
container it's not a a medium
space is not a substance and we have to
separate things from nothing
and space is nothing space is not a
thing you cannot say i moved through
space
no you traveled to the moon you did not
move through
space you did not travel in
you're not living in space so you did
not inhabit in space or whatever
uh you can't use the words in or through
with space because
space is not a container or a medium
through which you can go
space is nothing there is no such thing
as space that's why
you know the astronauts can't rub their
elbow against space because there's
nothing
there literally okay that's so so
the ether is not
a word that you can use in the context
of the rope model it's not
oh yeah what you're saying is the ether
is just in different format you're
saying that there's all this vibration
of ropes and so on in the background
yeah that's true but that's not the
ether these are
a bunch of particles either is a
particle theory
it's a particle hypothesis proposal
okay and so they should not be ever
confused